what do you think it's gonna take to
level the playing field there is like
discrimination against women like I'm
not a dude and I understand that now and
I think me waking up to that helps me
realize that also like what I have to
deal with in my difficult time getting
up a country radio chart is pretty much
nothing compared to like what a lot of
people have to deal with all day every
day for their entire lives
[Music]
you stuck inside I couldn't get you
burning house yeah big song climbs up
the charts down the sudden it's almost
like did you purples you take a step
back yeah no I didn't I kept the next
one was made a after that and would put
that out and that wouldn't caught up to
a certain spot and then unfortunately
with radio especially in country music
it's always a fight not just for women
it is extra fight for women but it's a
fight for everybody
[Music]
people are so afraid of playing
something different and losing listeners
because right now they're like too
terrified of losing listeners so they
want things to be familiar so they don't
give new things a chance I got to
haven't hit with something that was so
unique and didn't have drums and had
verses in 7/8 and was bizarre song by
all country music standards and to have
that be a hit meant that I had the
confidence and basically the freedom to
make sure that this next album was
whatever I want it to be and the first
single from that upcoming album is Diane
the song flips the script on the iconic
Dolly Parton single Jolene telling the
other woman's side of the story
[Music]
no he was your man
how do you turn through those times when
cuz like you said there's nothing
promised the record doesn't hit this
isn't working out yeah how do you kind
of regroup and come back and not let
that affect your self-esteem your
mentality yeah yeah when I first started
I came out of psychology research I was
a totally different career and then when
I came into music I was like well I'll
just be a writer you know and like
hopefully at some point I get enough
money just to get by like I don't really
I don't know any musicians expect to be
like a really fancy you know millionaire
and then I started singing my own songs
and then we took them around and people
we had a label come on board we had you
know see you start having only things
happen to you and unfortunately your bar
for what means success and happiness
starts going up too and then OH
Grammy nominations and like all this
kind stuff so then your bar is up here
so then when your next song is still
like released or like you know hundreds
of thousands of people people like come
up to me like all the time and are
talking about like made a song after
burning houses about that got them
through their divorce how that like how
I mean like a huge amount of healing
which is what music is for and that's
just a success I'm learning and I'm
grateful for all of it
you